definitely we recovered one individual
on the surface of the water
deceased and the search effort continues
for the remaining 12. my heart
and the collective heart of our team
goes out to the families
uh and to see core but we're giving it
all we have
the vessel itself remains overturned
on its darker side partially submerged
and grounded in approximately 55 feet of
water
there has been minimal environmental
impact to this point
uh and we are coordinating with state
and parish entities
to reduce any potential impact
c-corps is coordinating with the
families
uh with the next-to-kin communications
uh
and family reunification efforts uh so
at this time
uh i'll take any questions uh that you
might have
yes captain if you could uh go over a
little bit
if you know what was the t court doing
uh when it left fort boucher where was
it going
what role was it going to perform and
why
was it necessary for this boat to go out
in such a
treacherous condition so let me answer
by saying this
all of those things remain
under investigation we're trying to
figure this out as
we go uh we're talking to survivors
we're talking to the company
uh and so we're focused on the search
and rescue
effort more than anything right now but
those details will come out in the days
and weeks ahead as we learn more about
what went on but that
that information generally remains under
uh investigation as we figure out what
went on here so i don't want to
speculate
as to what may have happened until we
learned more fidelity what what happened
do you know what
where it was headed what company was
headed before anything like that so
c-corps
the vessel is a c corps vessel they were
headed
to maine pass we don't uh at this time
uh know exactly the mission they were on
our focus was that the vessel
has capsized and we're trying to find
the folks that remain unaccounted for
those details though we'll get them to
you as we learn them
uh in the days ahead great thank you
captain i have a question back here
please state your name and affiliation
sure justin michaels with the weather
channel yes as far as the weather i mean
it seems pretty
apparent that that was certainly a
factor in this can you go into any
extent
as far as detail related to the weather
conditions at the time
what exactly the boat was going through
anything specifically i will tell you
uh as i mentioned a little earlier that
what we know
of the weather conditions at the time is
that we had
80 to 90 mile per hour winds now
consider that
um challenging 80 to 90 miles per hour
winds and seven to nine foot seas
it's challenging under any uh
circumstances so we don't know
the degree to which that contributed to
what happened but we do know those are
challenging conditions to be
out in the maritime environment is what
we can say with with fidelity
okay and say your name is
so we did have some weather reports
yesterday there would be
uh some childhood weather but there was
this level
of weather was not necessarily
anticipating i think
you know i could say that with fairly
good confidence um
that we did not anticipate the weather
that we saw
was the ballast full what was their
cargo and were the legs down
or in motion so again
um not to keep repeating myself i
apologize for that
but those are details that are part of
our ongoing investigation and we will
get you that information
uh as it becomes available but i don't
want to
move into that realm right now our
investigators have engaged
and they are talking to folks on seeing
to the company and we're learning
as we go i will tell you the information
that we're getting has informed
the search effort but i don't have those
specific details that i've wanted
involves given
uh the ongoing investigation right now
and we will get that information to you
the days ahead
great please say your name and
affiliation by natasha robin
wwe yes um can you just explain what a
lift boat
is for for people with republicans who
really do not understand
what this what this vessel is sure i
i'll do my best in fact i brought one of
my senior experts
who does this 411 one of our senior
uh marine inspectors who understands
these types of vessels
through and through but i'll give you
just a basic um
picture of it and i'm going to ask todd
michelle one of our senior
inspectors to give you a little more
detail information but if you can
imagine
um a vessel um
almost like a uh a platform maybe with a
crane or two on it
and has legs that can be jacked
down towards the sea floor and as those
legs reach the sea floor
the platform of the vessel begins to
rise
and so those vessels can be stationary
and do work offshore
that's that's a limited um uh
layman explanation of what a jack or an
uber lift
vessel is especially jacob that's what a
little festival is todd you want to get
engaged here
just share a little bit on there
sure how you doing good morning my name
is todd michelle
uh todd mic agl
i'm a senior marine inspector here at
section new orleans
basically captain we had a pretty good
description of what a lip boat does
um this particular boat has three legs
one forward two are two forward one aft
basically they're 250 foot legs as the
legs jack down into the seat floor
the the whole the vessel is able to
raise up above the water line above the
sea conditions
to work on offshore platforms offshore
rigs
um they're mainly used for their cranes
it's a big part of what they
do offshore lifting personnel lifting
goods lifting
offshore equipment onto rigs
that's basically it they work kinda has
a regular vessel with
propellers and shafts when they're going
underway with their legs jacked up
they get on site jack their legs down to
the sea floor to remain stationary and
are able to work from that point
all right what was the length of the
legs that comes from 250 feet
sort of the draft of the boat i mean is
does it sit pretty shallow and would
maybe not be able to handle those seven
to nine foot waves i mean
does it have a all boats are designed
differently i mean typically it doesn't
have a deep deep draft like you will see
a ship
but um all boats are designed definitely
on what kind of wave heights or what
kind of conditions they can handle thank
you
thank you your name affiliation yeah my
name is travis
public radio um i'm wondering if you can
um talk about two things first off given
that the
dimension is
is that complicating the search and
rescue operation right now can you talk
about the current conditions
so to say
let me put it this way to say that we
have eights ten foot c's out there's
what we're seeing
and about actually at present i think
we're seeing
six to eight is the most recent with
about 15 to 20 nautical mile
uh winds and i think we got about four
nautical miles of visibility
um we're operating in those conditions
we are actively searching i will tell
you that i won't tell you that those
challenges
those conditions can't be challenging
but but we are out there and we're
committed
to the search and rescue effort my other
question was
i guess more like um you know if if
these
weather conditions were more known
that that these t is going to be so bad
would it be normal for this ship
not to go out there like is it weird
that this [ __ ] was
unlikely that it was out there well i
don't want to
again i don't want to speculate where
that's concerned
uh because the investigation is ongoing
but i will say this
as i said earlier the level
of impact of this weather uh
i won't say was wholly anticipated so i
don't want to say
that c corps was doing something they
shouldn't have been doing
and again all that all that information
will come out as the investigation
proceeds
okay thank you captain we have time for
one more question okay um please state
your
affiliation yeah i'm uh ramon vargas
with the uh
good morning good morning could you
describe how large
uh the area the search area is at this
stage
and um i know you kind of hinted earlier
about
you're going to take into account the
stormy conditions expected later but can
you go into detail a little bit more
about what that might prevent you from
being able to do or how long he can
serve that area well i'll put it to you
this way
we have a very fixed location uh we know
uh right now that the vessel is not
drifting we presume
uh that the vessel is a ground uh but we
are monitoring that active
conditions could change uh so we are
searching in that area and in a
successive pattern
out from that area given you know the
uncertainty as to where
these folks may or may not be so that's
that's how we're handling
this right now
you